good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy monday let's acknowledge the space
that we're in we do have a full week
ahead of us but you know what you guys
as long as we're acknowledging the space
that we're in like that's kind of all
that matters
yeah and it's really all you can do in a
situation like this when you do have the
whole week ahead of you so it's not the
it's not the best space to acknowledge
but if we do acknowledge it we can rise
we can grind we can hustle
and we can make today our [ __ ] because
we are we are rising and grinding
ground we could rising vine i did kind
of rose and grown today
i did i woke up earlier than usual like
so i had time to like put on a necklace
i was noticing your necklace but then i
forgot like my ring so you know
it's like okay so you're getting
divorced you can't win them all of
course of course
every other day that i forgot to put my
rings on no my rings are in a different
place than like the rest of my jewelry
box so why
um because i wear them every day and i
don't go into my jewelry box that often
got it i have got a new tray i don't
really wear a lot of jewelry but today i
was like this alpha could use a little
something something
yeah bland it's like a me outfit well um
i just have been dressing like it's
spring and it's fully not it's not today
and i just i'm like done looking and
feeling stupid and cold
i 100 but yeah we're in an interesting
position where this studio is literally
a hotbox it's a blaze
but outside it's [ __ ] freezing so i
just don't know how to like
acknowledge this space thank you
yeah but i'm so glad that you and i like
got the same memo today
like i'm done trying to make spring
happen it's not going to happen i'm like
always walking around like a little pink
thing like
freezing with like pollen up my nose
just like looking so [ __ ] dumb
and i'm like you know what fall vibes
[ __ ] it fall vibes
[ __ ] it that's the name of today's
episode i know i literally put my winter
boots in storage
and then took them out like i just
reverse spring cleaned because it's like
not spring no
my um loafers are like of a wool
material no you are
woolly vibes today woolly vibes only i'm
also moosey vibes today i've come to the
conclusion that like in the last month
i've literally put on
like 15 pounds somebody said to me i
think you look so great
thank you i mean somebody said to me do
you get cheek filler i'm like no no i
literally just gained weight but she
meant it as a compliment and i didn't
take offense to it because like i can
acknowledge the space that i mean like i
have gained weight and it's like how did
we get
here yeah no face is just like looking
so pizza recently that like that's how i
know like
big girls in town you know everybody has
their tails
for me it's just like how many times
people are gonna guess that i'm pregnant
i'm like nope just fast but that's not
about your weight that's just like
people like
can't get over the fact that me and ben
have been married for four years and
like we ain't having a kid like any time
soon
but you know what it's hard it's easier
for me because i actually am that like
that is a real problem i face
not you no no but like i do um i too by
the way i'm just backtracking because i
had some things i wanted to share i too
rose and grown this morning i was very
productive
tell us pull out my hair dyson air wrap
i'm like i'm just not
i'm not there yet but i still use it you
know so i feel like i'm getting my
money's worth
i just i know i'm supposed to use the
curling attachment
but my hair is far too long for it like
it doesn't
work and i'm just like really struggling
so but i'm working through it
did you see that new yes where you put
your hair through the hole
oh no they make an extension of the
curling wrap that's extra long for extra
long hair but it's like excuse me i just
spent six hundred dollars on this item
now i need to spend more money send it
for free seriously send it
right or at least let me customize my
additions
i totally agree but no did you see the
one where you put your hair through the
hole i don't think that's true
yeah also your hair's not that long so
like if it's too long for
that for then who is it for 100 percent
i also watch the real housewives of
atlanta i also watched the real
housewives of atlanta reunion this
morning
very productive because i wanted to talk
about it that is productive and
i filmed a uh another tick tock series
for you guys
look at that cup almost tell us about it
i feel like this is something
we can all get behind yes okay so this
is from the macro barista a lot of
people have been tagging me in his
recipes thank you so much
and he just like makes recipes for
everyone like whether you want something
healthy whether you want something
caffeinated
um so this is a nitro cold brew with a
pump of hazelnut three pumps of sugar
free vanilla and vanilla sweet cream
cold foam it is 95 calories
so therefore it is jackie approved and
i'm not gonna lie like it does taste
very good it it tastes a lot like coffee
but it's manageable
right and honestly like the second we
started filming my stomach started to
hurt so like i'm definitely gonna be
running right through big old duty after
this which is really all i wanted and
feeling
very energized like if that's more
possible than usual i'm feeling more
energized
so i really enjoyed this and i encourage
you to take a look at my series that is
being
critically acclaimed like honestly i
heard tribeca film festival like was
reaching out to your people like hey we
want to get the series up at the film
festival what do you think
i'm i'm just taking it slow because it's
been like a lot of like overwhelming
response
but there's just like you know the
critics
are quaking uh nicole richie's like
literally commented that like she can't
wait and she hopes i never stop doing
the series
well that's like that and paltrow as
well i just wanted to put that out there
she commented
twice and i'm still waiting for her
order yeah because that's going to be
another part of the series like trying
celebrities starbucks orders it's like
100
and when gp gives me the official goop
recipe i will try it but
she's just not like super communicative
today but like that's the thing about
this series where i feel like it's
become
bigger than you and it's like not about
finding the right coffee because
technically you just found it
no and honestly there was another one
last week that i found as well so like
i have found if i ever find myself like
needing a coffee i have a few really
good recipes that i
there's two that one of them got an
eight out of ten last week this one got
a six out of ten now i'm kind of
regretting it because i'm really
it's growing on me like as i sit here
but
i have found decent recipes but the
series is not really about the
destination it's more so about the
journey yeah and now it's like even when
you find the one like you can't stop
like everybody's waiting with baited
breath like what is she gonna try next
no i know and i also started another
series that i keep forgetting to do but
i really need to do it
which is here's what you missed on the
morning toast in 60 seconds or less i
think a lot of people
really appreciated the brevity at which
i wrapped up the morning toast and i
think it was great press for the toast
and i'm just really working on my tic
toc reels game because that's the future
of the industry and
i can't be left behind yeah no you can't
be but i
i'm you're volunteering just talking
about trying to stay behind
no i mean i like watching other people's
reels and stuff
um it's just it's a lot it's a lot it's
a lot of work and it's a lot of like the
people who but maybe if you had a
company
that you were passionate about if you
had a coffee order that you were
passionate about no but the people who
like do sickening rails that i enjoy
consuming like that is their full-time
job
and by the way i have so much respect
for it because i've for the last year
i've been on tick tock like as a hobby
but i've really taken it to the next
level in the last couple weeks and it is
a
full-time commitment like it is
exhausting exhausting like i go to bed
and i'm like house dude
yeah and then you get back on tick tock
to see whatever to see what everyone
else did that day
oh and by the way like the time limit is
still there and i literally press ignore
limit for today every single day okay i
might as well just take it off it's it's
so bothersome yeah because now you're
spending more time on tick tock like
pressing ignore but now
it's work like i used to just scroll
tick tick tock endlessly like
for pleasure and i still do that but i
also spend a lot of time on my creative
process
great well we're so glad that you are
working on your art
so important it's so important to have
passions and this really is yours
yes and also um i just want to wish you
a happy mother's day i'm sure
zach did not wish you a happy mother's
day much like ben didn't wish me
anything until he came home at 6 30 with
flowers and a gift it was an adult
coloring book
which was very thoughtful no card but
it's okay
i just felt like he had forgotten and
then when he was out he was like oh i
should get something for my deadbeat dog
mom
yeah no did you do anything i did not
get anything other than bruce love
he told me like that but sometimes
that's enough you know
that's really all i wanted from brew
like he was just being so extra special
just like loving on mom
and i was so happy to receive his love
it's a
it's a great day when you're receiving
love from bruno it's really
so true i think oh my god i didn't even
realize first of all theo is sitting
next to you which is so unbelievably
disrespectful
the day after mother's day nonetheless i
know well i think like it's auntie day
it's always anti-day here at the toast
no but i feel like because i didn't
haven't seen him in so long because of
the weekend he just like wanted to re-up
with auntie and then the rest of the
week he'll be with you
i feel like i literally took an adderall
i'm like wired i'm not really
liking this feeling i've never in in the
last 10 days
i don't really drink the whole thing but
like i am [ __ ] lit that's the cold
brew for you
i feel like i took it i've like taken an
adderall a few times in my life like i
feel like i just took one
and isn't that what you wanted like dial
it back a little
am i talking really fast i mean you're
just like your energetic self
are my eyes like crazy no they feel like
crazy
oh my god like drinks coffee once no
literally i'm fine
finally finishes her coffee i didn't
even
oh god take it away from her you know
i'm not gonna drink anymore i'm just
feeling like it's a lot you know
okay well great you got what you wanted
out of it you said your [ __ ] if things
are running through you
yeah and you have energy that's
illiterate please you're running through
me panic
no i'm fine um other than that it was a
fabulous weekend i finished the book for
the redheads we're recording today so
make sure to get your questions into the
redheads book club at gmail.com
um i did a poll because my plan was to
do a classic novel for
our next book club book but i've just
been on this historical journey like as
everyone knows
and i kind of want to take the redheads
on it with me and choose a book that
like i would be reading next and like so
everyone can see what i've been up to
yeah and i can always choose a classic
we all could choose a classic there's
always time that's why they're classics
right they never go out of style so i
that will definitely be
in my back pocket but i think for this
month i'm going to take you guys on this
journey that i've been on
i love that for you thank you for the
community thanks i actually think the
book that we just read twice in a blue
moon by christina lauren that's the book
of the month you would like
yes i'm going to add that to my list i'm
currently um i haven't picked up my
kindle in a while but i'm
like in the middle of this like terrible
book margot told me about but i keep
thinking about like i wonder what the
end is so i feel like that's the book
i don't know the name it's about like
this girl who's a writer and she picks
up this book and it's actually like
you know someone telling her story from
childhood like from her pov
interesting yeah sounds like super
spooky like magical realism it was
spookiness but i was into it very cool
by the way i just wanted to let you know
the new sally hepworth book
is out i know and she's your favorite
mother-in-law i just have like so many
books to read i know but you're watching
the bold type which is why you haven't
picked up your kindle
you guys my weekend was so full but all
i remember was last night like yesterday
for like seven hours i watched them all
type
first of all it was so good because it
was like major changes i finished season
one
cliffhanger spoiler alert jane gets
fired
she leaves her job at scarlet and she
gets fired from incest what's it called
inside
it was so good to like see someone
getting exactly what they deserved i
told you
she's just running around town thinking
she's literally who's like a famous
journalist dan rather
and she's [ __ ] not like she's not at
all and she just has the worst judgment
she doesn't listen to her bosses and she
thinks like her
no she's a literal step up from an
intern right yeah
she just became a writer six weeks ago
who
do you think she's the editor in chief
yeah and she just like uses her judgment
and like it's
bad judgment so it was just like nice to
see someone getting exactly what they
needed like a
big serving of humble pie and it's also
great to see like while she's flailing
you know
sutton is thriving like she's killing it
as a fashion assistant she's becoming
friends with all these influencers and
then she like had to put 500
worth of drugs on her corporate card
that was crazy and i actually was really
enjoying the show for a multitude of
reasons but i feel like
they i did work um at hearst for two
weeks as an intern before i was
asked to leave and i do have to say they
do really nail
like the whole magazine culture and also
like
the pr like what you would know
from for my two weeks two weeks that was
more than enough i worked at esquire
magazine in like the men's closet it was
torture i will never forget i had like
the two weeks they were filled with so
many stories
there was like this head intern who
thought like he was the [ __ ] and like he
kind of was because
he had this inspiring story of how he
had gotten the internship because he's
been obsessed
it was literally like he was jane he's
been reading esquire since he was 12
back at home and he had applied the the
traditional way and hadn't gotten any
traction and he like hand delivered his
resume and this like
you know hand bedazzled envelope and you
know everyone was so impressed he got
the internship he just tells the story
like to everyone
and he was a know-it-all but he did know
it all like so we did report to the head
intern because he was like
in charge but he was just one of those
people who was correcting you and he was
always right except one time we were
like talking about celebrities
and i was like carl delevingne and he's
like it's kara devlijine and i'm like
actually it's not like that's what i
remember and i was like he was such a
know-it-all
and then that's why i left but i did
really get a good grasp of the corporate
magazine culture
and like the building hearst was an
iconic place to be for two weeks
and i think they really nail it and they
also like kind of nail like the whole
nightlife
except like the fact that they live in
greenpoint and they just like
miraculously get to midtown in five
minutes every episode
that's the biggest plot hole yeah that's
always
what doesn't make sense in these shows
but for the right
for the sake of it like i don't want to
watch their commute so it's 50 percent
100 um i'm so glad that you're enjoying
it i'm loving it
i'm just i'm so glad i'm happy for you
that you have that you know what i watch
on friday night
finally the downtown movie finally
how was it it was it was cute that like
it was
that's not good it was cute that like
the gang was there like this
was there the king and queen came to
stay at downton
um but it was like a little stupid but
it was i don't think it was meant to be
like groundbreaking stuff
no it's just like nice to get the gang
back together yeah it was nice to get
the gang back together but like there
was like this whole like story line of
like so i guess when the king and queen
like come to stay at a house they bring
all their own
servants cooks butlers etc and then the
house runs like their house at home
i do the same thing when i visit other
people's homes but when
um when they came to downtown like the
show was about the downton staff
so the downton staff were like so upset
that they were usurped by the royal cut
out
yeah so and they like all like banded
together to like
you know lock them in their room so like
send them to london that sounds so
stupid
oh my god that sounds like the plot of
an actual disney channel original movie
it was so stupid they like all men in
the wine cellar they locked the chefs in
their room yeah they were so stupid
so that they finally like so that they
could serve the king and queen but
that's not protocol
no it's not protocol but it was just
like
a little silliness but it was really
good it was good
um well i'm happy for you i was um just
gallivanting around the tri-state area
this weekend
and i ended up having a lovely time i
had a bachelorette party on friday night
in the hamptons for my friend nicki
mazeltov
and it was very nice you know very
relaxing how were you feeling after
friday's show oh my god okay so the iv
like did really bring me back to life
and i really want to thank marisol from
iv drips for being like a real homie
like
she didn't have to you know put herself
out there and she did and i really
appreciated it and ivy drips was great i
felt
i still felt like [ __ ] but i was able to
survive
a three-hour car ride to the hamptons
with brian yeah
not only did i survive it like i had the
best time it was literally like the best
car ride ever we got mcdonald's
we watched the big shot bethany's they
were new episodes two more and me and
brian were just like
living for it and we put it on on his
phone we basically like listened to it
as a podcast
i was watching brian was driving but it
was so good we were just like
we were dying it's literally the dumbest
show but it's so good um
and then i went to the bachelorette
party and then saturday
i headed back to long island i had a
birthday party so i was just like kind
of being
like a long island socialite this
weekend which is kind of why i'm tired
you were being a princess of long island
yes yes i was okay well
part of the weekend was watching snl so
we need to get into it i have
so much to say without further ado to do
we need to get into the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and it should come as a surprise to
absolutely no one that today's episode
is brought to you by
the bruce the best electric toothbrush
on the market
works so well looks stunning and is
very affordable compared to most
electric toothbrushes which can uh cost
over 200
which is insane um if you just want to
like have a like a fresh start like
make a big change in your life start
with your toothbrush the brush has six
unique modes to customize your brushing
experience
the battery life lasts four weeks it
comes with a magnetic charging stand
and a compact travel case they also
offer a subscription program so you
never forget to change your brush head
again
bruce will ship you new replacement
heads every six months so you're never
stuck using a worn
down brush head they also come in a very
sleek design so jackie and i spoken
about how it's like
kind of the most stunning part of our
countertops i think a lot of electric
toothbrushes literally look like space
stations like there's like
huge mounts you just want a decluttered
lifestyle you know the kim yay way
and the bruce makes that possible their
electric toothbrush has a modern
aesthetically pleasing design that comes
in trend driven seasonal colors
and it looks great on your bathroom
counter get 15 off your brush toothbrush
kit and the refill plan
when you use promo code toast at
bruce.com join the millions of toasters
who have
literally changed their life and their
countertops with the brush
brush is spelled b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com
bruce.com code toast for 15 off
okay i'm already laughing because we
need to talk about snl
elon musk hosted saturday night live on
saturday night it was live
he confirmed and it was so [ __ ] good
okay i have so many thoughts because i
didn't watch because i was at a birthday
party
but sunday morning was like exactly what
i wanted to do first thing in the
morning before i even brush my teeth no
saturday night i literally took a nap at
seven o'clock so that i could
make it to snl i thought it went on at
like 11 15 so i turned on my tv at 11
and i literally watched 30 minutes of
news just waiting for elon i learned
so many things by the way no the it's
local news or it was local news like
first of all like i learned that this
week and last week that
temperatures are lower than what they
usually
are so that's also why i put on a
sweater today i was like the weatherman
said
the local news can make the happiest
person like
want to jump off a bridge oh it is so
depressing i
i actually cannot watch it no i know but
there's so much crime
so much crime so much tragedy gun
violence up in the city 166
from last year terrible terrible i can't
watch the local news
but i went on my phone i was like
wanting to see what people were saying
before i turned it on and
literally like people and it was like
news articles i don't know if it was
really like
the regular voices it wasn't the
people's voices it was like the media
like saying
bombs doge's tanking you know um elon
musk is so awkward
painful to watch and i'm like oh no and
i was expecting like a
full-on train wreck and i was
so confused after watching it because i
was like this was so
good like it was the sketches were top
tier elon was great elon was great let's
take it from the top
because his monologue first just i
literally was watching the monologue
like this like i was
laughing smiling so hard we really don't
know him i didn't know what his
personality was like at all and i just
felt like he was so
himself like he's yes a little awkward
yeah well he said he has asperger's so
he has he's a little socially
um awkward so he was just like totally
himself
about like all the things that people
say about him
make jokes about the son's name still
didn't tell us how it's pronounced no
cat running across the keyboard cat
writing cross keep
like his monologue was so quotable yeah
well the thing is is like
i think why a lot of people were like
this is awkward is because he is an
awkward guy and he
he just is like but i don't know i think
the fact that he was like so confident
in his awkwardness like made it
so funny and like endearing even the
sketch with his mom where mei like
literally
botched her lines so hard it's just so
sweet may like the month but with an e
thank you elon for spelling my name no
it was written so well i don't know who
wrote his monologue but it was excellent
and he looked i have to say like i was
just not expecting to like
find elon musk so hot you like my
stanhood is
through the roof i'm like doge cling to
the moon except not
a hundred percent of course am i
disappointed the doge is down
yes but you have to understand i got
into four cents it's still at 50 cents
i'm still in the red i mean in the green
and this is just the beginning elon
announced yesterday that he is literally
sending a rocket to the moon that is
paid for entirely by doge
it's the first crypto in space and he's
calling it doge and he's literally
sending doge to the moon
literally he's sending those to the moon
and yes i had i wanted to talk about
that but also
right before right as he was like as snl
was starting doge hit
.71 that's what i sent you and i think
because it got so high
people started selling inevitably
because they were like this is the high
it's gonna be all night and then it
totally tanked
i'm okay like i think it's it didn't
totally tank sorry it started at two
sets no but if you look at the charts
boom no i think it'll it it's a
long-term thing you can't just like get
in to get out and i'm really
here for the long haul um i just i have
more thoughts
of course because there was so much
controversy like so stupid around it
where like bo and yang and 80 bryant
were speaking out bow and yang did
participate in
many sketches with elon musk and i think
like
but what bow and yang had posted was
like when elon announced that he was
going to be on snl
he tweeted out let's see how live
saturday night live
really is and and boning was like what
the [ __ ] is this
now that i know elon and he's obviously
just like this like
quirky guy i could see him thinking that
like that's a hilarious joke and he's
like literally going to be a community
and like
i could see the whole thing so i
i was happy to see because i love bow
and yang i think he's literally the
future him and chloe are like literally
the future of snl so i was really happy
to see him participate
eddie bryant was very noticeably absent
from every sketch
except for the mother's day one in the
beginning which was far too long and
miley cyrus like did not sound good i
was so worried in the beginning
that elon wasn't going to do a monologue
because miley opened the show like miley
just inserting herself and
she should just join the cast no
literally it's so
weird that she's on every four weeks
yeah no and
a lot if you're a miley stand like you
are not going to like what i have to say
but i've really i've tried to be
open-minded when it comes to miley
cyrus's music career i've been very hard
on her
but i did think that most recently she
did kind of find her niche like with the
plastic hearts
and that um jualipa collab like she
hadn't had banger after being
in the midnight run amazing song i
really felt like she found her joan jet
vibe
and i was so disappointed because first
of all she didn't have any music to
promote
so i didn't really understand why she
was on snl then she literally stole that
guy's song and like
yeah he was there but i just can't
stress how weird it is to go on saturday
night
saturday night live and sing another
person's song like a contemporary song
and she is featured on like the version
the new they're they
they've obtained it to so here's here
this is the exact comparison lizzo
wrote a song feeling good as hell
killed it broke every chart this guy
i don't even know his name wrote a song
that went viral on tik tok it's like
became a huge song yeah it can turn a
wife into a hoe
love that's called without you i looked
him up last night so i should say it's
called the
kittly roy the kid leroy so
ariana grande the kid levroy ariana
grande and lizzo
after good as hell like was out for a
few years re-released it like together
and ariana had like a small verse on it
that would be like ariana grande going
on saturday night live and singing good
as hell and bringing lizzo like that
would have been weird
yeah so i just think it's so bizarre
that miley literally did a cover
and then her second song was a song that
is like so old someone else's song
that's a cover but the first sorry the
mother's day song oh i wasn't talking
the mother's day song was a sketch
sketch and she sounded really bad i'm
sorry um the first song was
not hers that kid should have gotten on
snl on his own by his own merit like
that song blew up that's what snl is for
yes whatever she's saying a cover and
then the second song
is like six months old like that's not
what snl's plastic
oh okay i didn't watch her and she did
not sound good
the mullet i had to say the thing about
miley is like what i've always said is
even though i don't agree with a lot of
her artistic choices
she always comes out and sounds amazing
that's like her biggest flex
flex is that she's multi-genre she kills
it
vocally she did not sound good she
sounded like she had laryngitis
yeah so i i feel like every time miley
comes out it's like oh wow this girl can
really sing i feel like it's a reminder
it's a reminder for obviously her fans
know that but it's a reminder for like
everyone old and young like well miley
cyrus she's not just hannah montana like
she's truly talented
she respects like older music yeah and
you always just like
have a new respect for her after
watching her perform live i agree she
sounded different apparently she had
vocal surgery and now her voice is a
little
changed that's what i read in toast
haberdark
oh yeah that's interesting um in the
sketch
of and that's a fun thing to have like
performers in sketches but like when
miley performs
every month she like just joined the
cast no i completely and like
why wasn't grimes the performer i was so
glad to see grimes as princess peach
me too and then to see her when they
were rapping rapping
yeah um so that was like a fun sweet
treat but
back to the main event yeah and let's go
sketch by sketch
the best sketch was jensey hospital
she's literally dead
she's literally dead it was sus for a
while and now no cap
no cap elon was great i feel like elon
really understands like internet culture
and i i just know bo and yang wrote that
sketch like i just know it so it felt
like a meeting of the minds and that's
why i was like so upset when bo and yang
was one of the people
who had spoken out because i actually
think he him and elon could be like a
great creative force
yes i totally and that sketch was the
culmination of so many things and it was
hysterical it was hysterical but just
like every time like
elon joined the sketch i was like it's
amazing no every time elon was on
i was just like quaking like i literally
i just couldn't believe it when he
showed up
in um chloe feynman's which was
literal she was incredible like she does
such good impressions but she's so
committed
to uli is that has she done before
no like it should be a recurring show it
should be because she was so good and
francis mcdormand like it was hysterical
but when they cut to the producer being
elon i dead ass did not know that was
him i thought it was someone else
really he looked so different yeah he
was just like
i feel like he's just such like a
perfectionist like he committed
to every role and you have to remember
the people who usually go on snl
are actors so like they're acting in a
skit or a sketch
and but elon's not so i thought he did
so good considering he's not an actor
he's just a genius
no and the premise of the whole wario
mario luigi
courtroom was so funny but i did not
like this this is like snl's thing they
have really good concepts for skits and
they like never know how to end them
they can't land the plane
so like when it became into like a cuomo
thing i was like
this is not funny you're like you want
to talk about governor cuomo and that's
what you're going to say yeah no and
it's like we're
tying in a courtroom no the quarter was
actually like a funny idea for a sketch
yeah and grimes's appearance was just i
didn't know at first that was her i
thought it was um chloe
fine and then when they were saying
their goodbyes i saw her on the stage
and i was like
princess peach i didn't uh before i
watched it i saw on twitter people were
like
sharing the picture like grimes on so i
knew that it was her but i probably
wouldn't have noticed her
if i didn't know that yeah totally so i
just loved
absolutely every minute of it and i
don't know if that's an unpopular
opinion
because so many people were like
dragging him on twitter but i thought he
did amazing i wanted to know like i'm so
proud of you it's really an unpopular
opinion like if you read the news i
literally just like googled his name for
a story and like the first article that
came up was like
cringy snl like it wasn't i just want to
say
i thought it was so good um like
literally the best episode i've seen in
so long
and i'm sure like they had a lot of
viewers i'm sure they did too and they
just like really leaned into
so many different sides of elon like
when he came on um
weekend update like pretty much as
himself right no but he was liron again
oh he was i think he was like an
accountant named leron but then my audio
on my tv stopped syncing with the mouse
so i had to turn it off whatever he was
just like being so funny he was like
like so nerdy talking about all the
things he loved like explaining
explaining what cryptocurrencies are
it was just like so fun to see him like
just like being himself no and when in
the last sketch
that was hysterical yeah where he was
just like reinventing the wheel the
liron of
he was elon musk of the wild west yeah
no and also
when he played himself in the mars
sketch where chad goes to mars
hysterical
sketch hysterical and you know in the
ones that were like pre-recorded not the
live ones
he actually did amazing like i rewatched
the chad sketch this morning
and i was like he could be a real actor
because it's not live and obviously like
you have memorized your lines and stuff
i thought he did so good and that other
pre-recorded sketch where
the quarantine quarantine the post
quarantine party when he was talking to
heidi gardner like it was just
hysterical yeah
and i just i i feel like it was really
kind of blown out of proportion like by
the media like everyone at snl's walking
like they don't want to be with elon
because it feels like everyone literally
everyone except for 80 bryant
participated and they all went out to
dinner a few nights before and i just
feel like they actually like got along
yeah no i think that everyone like went
into it with like maybe these ideas
about him but i think it seems like he
won them all over
and it was a pleasure and a joy to watch
it felt like one of those moments when i
turned it on i was like
i feel like so many people are like
historical tuning in for this
you know just like like the megan and
harry interview
like just like a cultural moment it's
not every day you see like
one of the smartest people of all time
like hosting a comedy show
no and he was in new york all week
driving his new testament
everyone kept like on twitter taking
pictures and sharing them because he was
spotted around the city it's like
literally i don't even know how to
describe it it's a spaceship
no and i got an uber on friday night
that was a tesla
by the way that happened to me recently
too i bet it was the same car and it was
so incredible i know we need to get a
tesla we need to get a tesla
where do we get one it's like a
self-driving horse which is just a horse
that was funny it was honestly 10 out of
10. like i just loved it
it was so good and i can't tell if
people are like going to make fun of us
for loving it
but i don't care i loved it and i feel
like there's so much bad
like publicity around it and someone
said this to elon like it was great
eleni did amazing grimes you did great
your mom was great you were hysterical i
fell in love with you let's get married
go elon go ela it's your birthday
go elon it was great seriously it was
[ __ ] great that's
our review our review 10 out of [ __ ]
10 that's nobody else's review
and i'm just not in the mood for the
slander it's like popular to hate on
elon musk like sorry he's changing the
world like and you're upset about it
because he's rich
leave him alone leave elon alone
seriously stop it um speaking of
snl next week olivia rodrigo i know he's
performing and
um kean peel uh keegan michael key
yes i'm definitely watching that even
though we're oh we're gonna be in
nashville okay i'll watch you in the
morning on the plane oh yeah programming
update we are taking a trip this weekend
but we will be in studio monday tuesday
wednesday thursday is audio only
friday we're starting over some we're
starting summer fridays yeah a little
early even though it's like we
just talked about for 20 minutes so it's
not spring and now or do you have a full
weekend
um all in all the takeaway of this
episode leave it elan alone
snl was a 10 out of 10. and if you find
yourself not believing that
reevaluate check yourself um i totally
agree
um and dosh is literally going to the
moon oh let's check where it's at
actually so it had gotten to 0.71
and now it was like down to like four or
five because there was so much
doge like fanfare on the show that it
was going to go up
but i guess i clearly thought wrong
what's it at point five
okay just play play the game
don't keep checking no i'm fine i think
also this news of josh literally going
to the moon should make
go up did you see that ethereum's at 4
000 i don't [ __ ] with a theory no but
like if you're in the crypto game
that's just good to know that your
cousin ethereum got to 4 000.
yeah that should know all sinking traps
rise tides
rising tides raise all ships exactly are
you ready but sinking ships do
tie rise that is true not always but
generally speaking but don't forget that
are you ready for our next story someone
call brielle biermann because juliana
rancic is leaving e's red carpet
we are literally soothsayers
soothsayers we spoke about this on
friday how you were literally gonna have
to take
giuliana rancic's job from her cold dead
fingertips and she wanted to prove me
wrong because
literally five minutes later she
announced on instagram she's leaving
ease red carpet coverage after 20 years
the live from the red carpet staple
announced over the weekend that she's
thrilled to start a new adventure
developing stories with e's parent
company nbc universal
she said after 20 years hosting ease red
carpet i decided to step out of my red
carpet heels into a new pair of shoes
one of my passions is great storytelling
and i am thrilled to announce a new
development deal with e's parent company
nbc universal
where i'll be producing and bringing
stories to life this announcement is
very like
duke and duchess of sussex um bringing
stories to life
yeah and like so i guess she left e news
like
10 years ago and everyone thought that
was like the end of her on e but then
she was still doing red carpet and then
e news got cancelled so it didn't even
matter
so it felt like she never left but this
is like the official last job she has at
e correct
yes i believe so i mean i wouldn't be
surprised if once again we're wrong and
she's done belly popping yeah right but
no i do feel as though we generally see
her on the red carpet and this is no
more red carpet
i'm like really okay with that like i
can't stress enough how i really feel
like
i appreciate her work but it is her time
it's ryan seacrest's time and like let's
just give
the mic to tanya rad like it's literally
tanya rad every girl wanted to be the
next giuliana rancic
and tommy rad actually is the next
juliana rancic i totally agree
also since juliana's like doing a new
series and development with nbc like
that sounds like a step up from being
like the host of the red carpet
so everybody's just moving on moving
along jason kennedy and tony ride are
like the future of e
and it's about time they start acting
like it i don't know but his show like
didn't it was the dumbest idea it didn't
go was it called the big room
in the room in the room yeah no one
cares yeah no
but he he's doing okay like justin
sylvester
morgan oh in terms of like the top the
daytime oh yes in terms of like what
they do
best which is like pop culture recap
news commentary
red carpet the morgan stewart the jordan
uh the justin sylvester the lady sitter
the hunter nina even though karissa
announced last week that she's leaving
which is a
real shock because she it was is the
backbone of
the club she's like the the host and
then like morgan the captain of the ship
yeah they get to like you know do
squeegee on both sides i wonder why
i know i found that to be really
surprising i mean she just had a baby
maybe she just wants to focus on her
family but i don't know
i don't know maybe she got a different
job somewhere else but i found that to
be really surprising too so it does seem
like there's change-ups happening over
at e
there's always things moving at eight
because everything gets canceled after a
month
i know that must be like a tough place
to work when it's like every other
volatile
things are changing so much yeah but
that's the latest
and greatest and that's what you missed
on e very good
i like that yeah um before you move on
can i just let everyone know about
ipvanish today's sponsor please do
ipvanish is a virtual private network a
vpn for short
a vpn is a super important tool that
helps you safely browse the internet
you can use a vpn on your computer
tablet phone even things like your fire
stick when you're streaming media
when you use a vpn all of your data
becomes encrypted what you're reading
what you're searching what you're
watching whatever it is that you're
doing
that's important because what you're
doing on the internet is absolutely
nobody else's business but yours
ipvanish helps you remain anonymous and
secure on the internet
so this is the official sponsor of
former toasters for listeners of the
show
ipvanish is offering an incredible 65
off
just 3.49 for the first month or 31.49
for the entire year
and here's everything you get with
ipvanish anonymous ip addresses which
means your personal ip address
cannot be tracked by anyone you can
circumvent any online censorship
ipvanish has more than 1500 servers in
70 plus locations
and you can get protection when using
public wi-fi remember with ipvanish all
your data is encrypted so no one can
snoop on what you're doing
and 24 7 support you can email them chat
with them even call them
they're there to help you so if you want
to claim your 65
savings go to ipvanish.com toast that's
ipvanish.com
toast getting plans at just 3.49
a month or 31.49 a year this is the time
to sign up with our discount
and their current promotional offerings
you can get a vpn for 65
off their usual offering that's
ipvanish.com
toast to get the deal and start
protecting yourself online
love it okay ready for our next story
yes little mix is about to become
lethal mix yes perry edwards is pregnant
announcing her pregnancy a week after
her bandmate leanne so we've got two out
of three little mix members pregnant
such a beautiful time for little mix so
many changes in the little mix
family jessie nelson has departed and i
it
seems to be pretty permanent based on
like interviews she's doing she
did like kind of a big like interview
basically saying like her breaking point
was
on this music video set where she just
like literally did not feel like herself
and she felt so insecure
and she didn't really say anything bad
about the girls i feel like they're on
decent terms but i just think like she
left
the environment for her mental health
yeah i understand and now two of them
are pregnant there's just like so many
changes but i feel
good about it i don't think that little
mix is breaking up like i feel strong
because if you follow little mix like
they're still putting out fire content
songs videos they just put out an album
like with the three girls like they're
not stopping and jesse's departure like
has not slowed them down whatsoever
and now like the fact that two of them
are pregnant at the same time so like
it feels as though they'll all maybe
want the same things and like it will go
faster here and slower here like
it's it seems really nice and actually
probably is really nice to be in a girl
group and
be pregnant at the same time as another
girl so you don't feel like you're
you're being like left behind or
something
100 and also perry and leanne are both
with soccer stars
so it's just like so cute it's kind of
like an ideal
situation like i'm i'm happy jessie i
miss her
but i'm glad she's taking care of
herself and i think that like
that's kind of like better no like i
think everybody is where they want to be
and doing what they want to be doing and
that's all you can
ask out of your favorite girl room
percent and i just feel good about it
like yeah
i saw my literal my instagram this
morning like when i opened it it was my
first picture was
perry's belly yeah me too and i was just
so excited especially knowing that
leanne announced last week i'm sure they
like coordinated their announcements
they would each have their time
but like they'll be in this together
yeah and i'm just like happy for perry
you know because she's been on a journey
with the zayn of it all shout out to my
ex you're really quite the man you made
my heart break and it made me who i am
um i just feel like it's been a long
journey a very difficult journey i
actually saw her in concert and she
started breaking down crying like right
after she broke up with zayn well same
work up with her
and you know it's hard zayn like bounced
to gigi who's like the most perfect girl
in the world and like they had a baby
together and like everyone like dies for
them so it's a tough spot to be the
other girl you know in another country
but she bounced back even better she's
giving me joe jonas and sophie turner
vibes like 100
they should all hang out especially
because sophie
is british yeah yeah i just feel like
it's very complicated like
i feel like joe and sophie don't want
any like they'll they'll hang with
taylor swift like they'll laugh about
any drama they'll laugh about this and
that but like
they don't want to touch the gigi and
zayn web
yeah well it's tangled for them too yeah
no i just feel like like that's
the x that's like the real one you know
yeah like
everyone's connected that's the thing
like i could literally connect two
random people
like via like hookups you know because
like
this generation like well they're not
young hollywood anymore they're like all
having babies now but like they've
literally all hooked up with each other
yeah it's just like someone sexual i
know but like that's what they should be
doing yeah no it's fabulous
but like you know what picture lives in
my mind rent free share
the picture in london of calvin harris
taylor swift
carly kloss i think she's being like a
fifth wheel because i don't think
josh kushner is that his name yeah he's
there and then
gigi and joe jonas like the five of them
like that's just like
was that when they're on the boat yeah
they were on the list
maybe london actually whatever the five
of them on a boat like it that is just a
picture that like i can't believe exists
first of all because taylor in a boat
with her ex
joe jonas and now after like reliving
fearless it's like so real in my
mind and the fact that gigi and joe
jonas were at it
like ever together like it's just like
it's crazy and then like the carly cloth
like it's just like so much
it's crazy and the calvin harris like
it's just a lot yeah it's a lot
well i hope that your brain like has
space for the next story thanks a lot
if that's what's living there no it's
living there like so rent-free
it's crazy they need to start paying you
i saw a hysterical meme
i know what from adam the creator yeah
this lives in my mind rent-free and it's
a picture of a brain
i literally when you said this lives in
my mind i'm free that's what i was
thinking i was cracking up
such good smart content totally are you
ready for our next story little horse
drama
oh no yeah kentucky derby winner medina
spirit
fails the post-race drug test trainer
bob baffert calls it a gut punch because
we reported last week medina spirit won
the
derby the [ __ ] and that the trainer now
had won the most derbies yet but medina
spared the horse that won the 2021
kentucky derby last weekend at churchill
downs
has failed a post-race drug test the
horse did the horse did i didn't even
know you could drug a horse
he had um a high level of an
anti-inflammatory drug
and that's what he tested positive for
no um
betamethasone anti-inflammatory is like
advil so like
but it's also a steroid this drug but
i'm sure i that's where the confusion
lies this is what the trainer said he
said yesterday i got the biggest gut
punch
in racing for something that i didn't do
he said he said that the drug test was
an
injustice to the horse on sunday
churchill down suspended the trainer
from entering horses on the track
so his leg career is over a second
positive test called a split sample is
required before horse can be
disqualified as the kentucky horse
racing commission regulation state
so they have another test that they need
to go through if the findings remain
true medina spirit will be disqualified
and mandalon the runner-up will be
declared the winner
churchill down said in a statement good
day to be mandalone the trainer said
this shouldn't have happened there's a
problem somewhere it didn't come from us
i don't know i'm not really believing
like do the tests lie
like i don't know tests don't lie i'm
glad that they have protocol in place
like there's going to be another test
i didn't know what that first of all you
could like drug horses and that like
they were all required to take a test
well you could
i guess like juice them up yeah i guess
but like
a horse is so big like how many roids
they have to take think about it a lot
that's so sad the victory's in jeopardy
and everyone is at the edge of their
seats
i'm quaking honestly imagine like you
won the conduct like you
your family no you put bet on a horse
and you went in and they like you went
38. okay but what does it do with the
bets i don't know
they keep their money i think that makes
sense that'll be what are you going to
collect from people
they've already taken their money
they've already taken their money and
spent it
well it depends maybe they're saving but
still maybe
that's good that adds a layer of
confusion that just stresses me out but
then if you had bet on
me curio whatever mandalore um
then you would feel entitled yeah that's
tough maybe they have to pay out
everyone
drama drama that's why we need
self-driving horses which are just
horses
i need a tesla like that's the moral of
the story claudia
i need a tesla i know you can't lease
that you have to pay for the whole thing
no
i think it's a good investment i think
are there charging stations in the city
i feel like most parking garages
probably have that yeah i think you just
need an outlet
no i don't think so i think you just
need an outlet no you need like a whole
station no you just need a little
wireless charger i just like love the
idea
lol he should make that i'm sure he's
working on it he's working he's working
so hard
i did you see a few weeks ago when kylie
went in that tunnel yes
the boy me and ben spoke about it on the
toast okay
when you weren't here sickening
claustrophobic i would literally rather
die no but like knowing you're in elon's
tunnel like i would just stress the
tunnel no no i
i would be so scared there's literally
no hundreds of miles behind you i know
and
hundreds of miles in front of you okay
what if your car breaks down
elon would never do that to you but yeah
i totally agree
horrible is there a convenience store
inside
no there's nothing but if you need gas
what if you get hungry what if your car
breaks no wait
what if someone in the car has a heart
attack can i tell you something crazier
that i just thought of like no
you're in the tunnel the car is built to
like fit in the tunnel on the tracks
like so say you got stuck can you even
open the door or do you hit the wall
stop i think there's probably room to i
don't know you gotta open the trunk
the trunk sunroof no but is it like no
it's so
not right i'm not okay so brave
and chris yeah i had a dream this is so
pathetic i had a dream chris jenner came
to one of my comedy shows and i was like
so excited
stop jake posted it on instagram like it
was the funniest thing i never thought
like that would never happen these days
dreams are called manifests
so instead of saying like oh i hope this
happened today i'm manifesting it and
then and then it'll happen apparently
yeah and i was like trying to figure out
how she got invited manifest it
oh my god okay are you ready for a fifth
and final story
that's not so much news is just like
something i think people should know
yes i think they should know too because
i read this story and i was like oh i
didn't know this and i was actually like
wondering if this was it's a little tax
news you need to know since like no one
will tell you how to do your taxes right
no like you just have to guess exactly
how to do it
but the money that you donated to
gofundme probably
isn't tax deductible there has been no
shortage of need during the pandemic and
to help meet it friends neighbors and
customers have set up hundreds of
thousands of crowdfunding campaigns
yes an american has started a coveted
related fundraiser on its site every two
minutes since march 2020.
wow the donors shouldn't assume that
their contributions are tax deductible
and fundraising
fundraising organizers should not assume
the money they have raised won't be
taxable
giving money to an online fundraiser to
help those in need or to fund a
creator's project on platforms like
kickstarter
is not going to be tax deductible unless
the money raised is going to an irs
designated charitable organization known
as a 501c3
right so unless the gofundme organizer
was a 501c3 which
if you're donating to individuals it's
most likely not no if you're donating to
gofundme that's the point of gofundme
it's for regular people not people
who have tax deductible 501 c3 companies
yeah so
if you were planning on counting that as
tax deductible probably
don't open me needs to fix that gofundme
needs to fix that people would be more
inclined to donate more people love tax
deductions it's a great incentive to do
charity
this is a disgrace it truly is no the
government and gofundme need to
sync up and figure this out the platform
like over the last couple of years has
blown up and this is
this is a problem and the idea that all
of the the contributions in total
are then taxed right like a family is
right
people are collecting for their medical
bills it's to get they rate they raise
50
000 and then they literally are left
with 25 because of taxes
then what's the point then you need to
raise a hundred to get what you actually
need
no that this is wrong and i'm i'm glad
that we're calling it out me too i think
more people should be talking about this
because on the one hand i just wanted
you guys to know like don't
like that don't write off your taxes as
a tax deduction more people
donated to gofundmes this year than ever
before i know that i did
yeah and i was curious and i even
googled like is gofundme tax deductible
and i learned something to this effect
but i was still a little unsure and then
i saw this article today i'm like i
think more people should know that
and also let's talk about this yeah oh
my god my middle finger
my middle finger nervous she was not
getting better tendonitis did you get a
sleeve
but you know what i might try it your
way soon because just get the splint and
walk around the house with it a splint
will change it overnight
now i hate when people have the solution
in front of them and they don't [ __ ]
take it
physical therapists now it's hurting in
the knuckle tell me what to do
take the splint it'll change your life
fine and if i'm wrong i will wear a
splint on all 10 of my fingers
for an entire show okay i think the
punishment should be of my choosing
fine okay but i like my idea okay fine
okay
um should we dive into real houses of
atlanta yes and speaking of real houses
of atlanta someone's hand looked like
they were wearing a splint on every
single finger
who's was that oh i don't know the
outfits
we have to get into it let's get into it
before we get into it we're gonna
annihilate some outfits brought to you
by blueprint test prep
thank you blueprint this needs to be
said you're never quite sure if the way
you're studying is going to drive
results
people have used index cards for years
you just read them over and over and
over
but it's hard to commit to studying and
get into a routine because of all the
distractions i was
never a good studier i was never a good
test taker
but that's because i didn't have
blueprint test prep for law
and medical school you've got to try
blueprint their test prep delivers
life-changing score increases
on average their students receive
11-point increases for the lsat
for your future lawyers and 13-point
increases for the mcat for the future
doctors
that is a big deal here's a shocking
thing that they've learned at blueprint
over the years
when you are bored you don't retain
information very well blueprint was
founded on the idea that test prep can
actually be entertaining and effective
they use unique animations memorable
graphics plus humorous pop culture
references to make your experiences
engaging and enjoyable
they're also the only dynamic study plan
tool that creates your personalized
study plan at the click of a button
your plan will outline exactly what to
study when evolve with your busy
schedule and sync to your phone so you
can stay on track
they only hire the best instructors to
teach for blueprint you must score in
the 98th percentile or higher on their
exam
and they turn down over 90 of people who
apply to teach for them so you know
you're only getting the best of the best
instructors
you get personal analytics after every
press test and their numbers don't lie
they have helped over 50 000 lsat
students
and 60 000 mcat students improve their
scores with a 4.8
trust pilot score you know you can trust
them so all of our studious toasters
if you are studying for the lsat or the
mcat and you want a personalized
effective
study plan check out blueprint
blueprint has an incredible contest
going on right now where you can win 20
000
towards your law school tuition just
head to their site if you want to enter
to win
plus blueprint has an exclusive offer
for morning toast listeners they very
rarely offer discounts
this this big but for the first 100
listeners of our show
who go to blueprintprep.com and use the
promo code toast
you will receive 20 off that's
off your lsat or your mcat class if you
go to blueprintprep.com and use the
promo code toast
20 off that's over 200
off your study plan love it okay let's
get into reality
first i love that there was a theme and
i think a lot of times there is a theme
it's like very
vague all white but no this was like
dominatrix dungeon
it was disgraceful like so many i
actually think you know it pains me
because i
really especially after last night's
reunion i can't stand her
kenya looked amazing can you listen like
she was literally
i loved her bun her bun was elegant
her dress was stunning it was just it
was a look
yeah and i don't know if it was good
because everyone else looked terrible or
it was just like good on its own
yeah i think it was good on its own but
then it was also like sinking tides like
rey's one shot yeah
so the episode was frustrating because
i'm very much on team porsche when it
comes to the bolo thing it's not it's
it reminds me of denise and brandy it's
not about whether or not denise and
brandy
hooked up it's not about whether or not
bolo and porsche hooked up it's the fact
that it's nobody's business
it's out just to play kenya's advocate
for a second
um the difference is if denise and
brandy hooked up
in the house when they were you know in
santa barbara yeah and kenya was like
hanging on to that but the thing is like
the women had an agreement before that
they took their mics they sent producers
to him they covered all the cameras
obviously they didn't do a good job
but they had a mutual understanding
amongst everyone that this was
off camera and porsha brought it up rep
kenya brought it up repeatedly the next
couple days
yeah and i have a lot of respect for
candy
because candy knows exactly what
happened and she's not being a gossip
girl about it even though she very well
could because it's very clear that she's
holding on to
what happened between her and portia
four years ago which i understand
because it was
insane well i don't know if she's
holding on to it as much as like this
just reminds her so much of it so she's
viewing it through that lens whereas
it's not like every decision she made
for the last four years was like
because of that do you know what i mean
no i don't think so either but it's
obviously like she has trauma from it
because it was like a
heinous accusation that's not something
you just forget yeah
but at the end of the day i was just
like i i could not get on board with
kenya she's just like so
one like she doesn't listen to what
anyone's saying she's just like there to
get her point across and she's wrong
like she's
fully wrong yeah i just think in general
like i understand her point of like it's
a show
and that's what we do and we're at work
and i yes
technically that's right i just like
hate when people use that as an argument
because it's like
but you're still a human being and
and even andy like didn't get on board
with that and andy's the executive
producer of the show i feel like yeah
i guess it does kind of remind me of
denise and um
randy because it was like rina like
let's talk about it like we don't need
to talk about it no and kind of the
whole theme of the episode was like it's
a personal matter it shouldn't be on tv
and that's like with the prophet like
drew wan i mean
she's so wrong and she's so annoying
she's making toyah like
extremely likable yes i know even though
toya has been acting like insane the
whole season
i agree like drew is such a [ __ ]
drama queen and this is the
biggest like storyline chasing moment
ever like
nobody cares this is nothing and so then
it turns out okay he's a false prophet
so literally you should be thanking toya
because then that false prophet would
have blessed your baby
yeah it was so stupid it was so silly
and like the
just the whole thing i thought it's like
this is where we're at the recording
like she just did
everything she just woke up and it's
like i'm gonna make the audience like
toyah the recording was so
embarrassing like there was nothing
there no nothing
not a single morsel of proof so i just
i thought it was just so silly yeah and
you're right it did make toya end up
being
more likeable and i just need an
explanation on why shamia was there like
she didn't say one word
no idea and i guess she's a friend of
but so is marlo technically and so is
toyota like they're not on the same
level right they had such
bigger roles both of them should have
and could have been housewives like in
terms of their actual air time do you
think toya will be a housewife next year
it's possible i i would i would like her
to get one
i liked drew up until this profit thing
so i'm like a little disappointed
in her and i just put together that drew
is in white chicks i sent you that
picture yeah
she plays um one of the chicks's
girlfriend friends friend yeah so they
show up at that party in the hamptons
um that was iconic but yeah also
interesting to know she used to be
friends with lebron james or she is
friends with a bronzer
she said he used to no she said she's
been friends since
it sounded confusing the way she worded
it because she meant i think she meant
to say they've been friends since before
he was in the nba
i think or they stopped being friends
once he became i think like they were
friends before he was in the a
mba and then like people go and do their
own thing yeah
um so i was like annoyed because i did
really like drew for most of the season
and i thought she was right in the whole
toya thing tony was being mean to her
about the wig like i really was on her
side but she totally lost me like
the dumb i can't believe we're like
hinging the final part of the reunion on
this
dumb [ __ ] conversation yeah oh and
then when she asked everyone to pray
and kenya was literally like this is
blasphemous she was right i agree
it was blasphemous that was so like fake
it was
so silly so silly and by the way i'm
actually really shocked like tanya is
gone yeah she wasn't like it's so
obvious like
tanya portia and bolo they did it like
nobody i don't even care
but porsha had nothing to lose she's a
single girl she's a consenting adult as
andy said like she can do whatever she
wants
tania was not that free so i just can't
believe like actually right but like
tanya is the denise in the situation
yes and just like denise like she's
bouncing but i really
found tanya to be so annoying so many
when she first came on the scene like
when they were in tokyo with nene like i
just
i did not like tanya and she has grown
on me so much i think she's such a nice
girl
and i'm really sad that like i think
this is the end of the road for tania on
housewives
oh you're sad about it yeah i ended up
really liking her she really grew on me
yeah i just you got to protect the home
your real life
yes a hundred percent mm-hmm but she
also has like an interesting
there was like stuff there you know with
like her long-term partner fiance
that woman from the cookie shop like
there was just a lot there but also
never explore it i just want to say that
i'm glad that marlo and kanye are still
on their path to friendships i'm not
i know you i just i think we see it
differently i'm i'm
so i've been such a big marlow fan and
i'm so upset that she's choosing kenya
over porsha
she will regret that decision i'm
telling you i don't think and i don't
think she sees it as shoes in kenya over
porsha i think she would say that
porsha has made it into like her or me
but she like
i don't think that's true at all i think
she intended to be on good terms with
kenya while still maintaining a
friendship with portia the thing is
we're in an interesting crossroads now
because like
kenya and porsha both sat next sanity
they're clearly like two of the biggest
stars
but there's no future for them and it's
like the same thing every season like
it's just like getting kind of tired and
i honestly feel like one of them has to
go for like the show to really move
forward in a real way
or they have to find a way to move past
their stuff which i don't think
did last season i don't know if it's
possible but like really anything's
possible
yeah that's true you know daniel staub
and theresa judice came back together
anything is possible
it's so true so it was honestly like a
fine season there was a lot of hype
around
the bolo thing and i think they
delivered but that happened really early
on in the season and everything after
that was just like
the false prophet like are you kidding
me yeah that's when you know but i think
like it's part of this like 20 20 year
of content yeah like i think they were
filming like during just like a rough
coveted time and there was only so much
to do it wasn't as bad as oc
so right that's the bar that's the bar
the real housewives kids was on i did
not watch it i fell asleep so early but
i will watch it and give my thoughts at
some point
um but did you see the biermanns just in
bravo news have been posting a lot
online like
don't worry like we'll be back on your
tv soon yeah they're doing something
with peacock called like biermann brunch
is that what you think that's what kim
posted no
kim posted a story saying like they will
be back on your tv soon that's it
biermann brunch where did i read that
the biermann bunch i think that was just
like a birmingham bunch
so people are suspecting that it's on
peacock and i agree i don't know why
they would change the name
i read it as biermann brunch but i guess
she was saying the biermann
bunch yes but why would it be a
different name if it's on peacock
it wouldn't need to be a new name no it
wouldn't but maybe
it's going to be a new show who knows
i'm upset and i know nobody else is they
want to re-brand like don't be tardy is
a little
tired tired i agree so if it's a new
home a new show i think it's actually a
good idea if they change the name
yeah i i actually think they would do
well on peacock and peacock like of all
the streaming service is just like not
hitting it at
all well i feel like they're in a lull
right now just because like there's
nothing that's like so pop and i feel
like hbo max has like everything right
now i love hmx i even watched a little
bit because zach was watching ellen's
next big designer ellen's next top
designer ellen has a new show she's not
on it but it's called ellen's
next america she's not on it but her
name is in the title it's so weird it
has nothing to do with her it's not her
vibe at all it's like the next
designer what are they designing for um
[Music]
decor home ellen has a line
it's really good the show it's like
premium design why isn't she on it
i don't know and i don't know why her
name is on it because it makes me like
not want to watch it but
are they designing for her home decor
company no zach said that the winner
gets a hundred thousand dollars but what
they should get is like
a laundry with like a collaboration line
with like cb2 or something because
ellen's company ed it's huge they sell
that bed bath and i actually have some
of the [ __ ] like sure i don't even know
it was ellen
it's just good stuff the prize does not
seem worthy of like these people are so
talented the episode i watch i had to
design like a children's
um backyard like playground and like but
they do it like aesthetically and like
monkey bars but make them cool right
and it was it was really interesting
that is so bizarre it's so bizarre but
yeah there's nothing
there's nothing anchoring peacock like
they thought they were gonna make their
bones on the fact that they have the
office and friends or whatever
but hbo max has friends never mind and
they have the office and like nobody
cares
um but i do think that the housewives
all-stars whatever it's going to be
called
being on peacock like will be good for
them but when is that going that's not
going to be ready for months
yeah peacock just like kind of sucks
yeah of all the streaming service
launched in the last year
i think it's probably like the least
successful in my mind i don't think
besides quibby
why it's bigger i just think there's
highs and lows like
it just because you're not watching
something on peacock right now
like you just have forgotten about it
which i feel all the way like
all the time about some of the things
that i subscribed like i guess but i
really i use all of my subscription
services for different things like and
i've i
i watched when peacocks were about
friends on hbo max oh
that's what i use hp max right now i'm
watching big shot hulu i'm watching the
bull type disney plus like i do when i
have a movie night with ben like
everything serves when something gets
trending on netflix like everything
serves a purpose
peacock doesn't fit in there i'm curious
if i'm the only one like i just watched
the downton movie on peacock
um i think that yellowstone was on
peacock oh okay
so i don't know i watched nyc prep like
when i first
got peacock and it was just like not
enough to keep me even though it was
really good
lol um so that's our show correct yep
that's our show nobody else's
don't get it twisted ooh jinx um okay
well thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have ready to catch blocks all the
places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find us the morning shows leave
a five star view about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you have
an amazing day you guys we will see you
tomorrow
[Music]
goodbye
boom